hey buddy Zach tomorrow's Thanksgiving
I'm in New York and I'm gonna see if a
stranger will invite you there
Thanksgiving dinner let's go so what are
your plans for Thanksgiving we're
actually going to my sister's in
Westport but my family watch football do
you um do you think I could I could come
would you let me come to dinner for sure
really for sure
yeah I mean I I guess you could come we
were mine yeah you're in bed so this is
real you're willing to let me come over
yeah sure
okay um you know just hold this yeah I
have a pen somewhere sorry it's like
give me your like address or number
however best to reach you oh here's my
number great yeah so we'll meet you at
the westward train station sounds like
you're trying to ditch me oh all right
so I'm gonna call your number just to
make sure is that a three oh yeah hey
you it's me shove a good huh yo Mia
don't me to bring anything oh really
bring yourself just yourself enough no
food what happened for you great this is
this is going great is better than I
ever could have expected so so far
everyone has said yes I can come to
their Thanksgiving dinner which is
awesome but also a little surprising we
think the microphone might have
something to do with it so I'm gonna
ditch this and then just go ask people
so let's see what happens
excuse me I have a quick question do you
have one second like I don't have
Thanksgiving plans would you let someone
like Annie come um no
sorry I'm flying home tomorrow I'm from
Las Vegas so I'm thinking so it's not
ours would they be weirded out if I came
I think so yeah yeah okay of core of
course of course I'm sorry to bother you
excuse me I have a question
would you be okay with me joining your
Thanksgiving dinner you have anywhere
else to go
yeah sure I'm actually I'm filming the
video for BuzzFeed and I'm wondering
would you mind like coming and talk to
me about it real question I want
everyone to feel like they've got a
place to stay for Thanksgiving and have
a sense of family even if they don't
have family nearby I feel like I'll warm
and fuzzy inside this is great you guys
are great people thank you thank you
love mix brooke around
please say okay we have two Jews
together you eat okay
Thanksgiving is tomorrow and we're all
gonna spend it together x-pipe it should
have started as a song I would have done
much better but Happy Thanksgiving
oh I'm nice I'm good yeah I enjoyed it